[Musique]
86 milliards d'euros parce que selon les
estimations de l'observatoire français
des conjonctures économiques
c'est-à-dire à peu près selon vos
calculs mathieu plane mais qui date du
14 octobre on va y revenir le sait le
montant de l'épargné forcée des ménages
sur l'ensemble 2020 c'est-à-dire
l'épargné forcée
c'est en gros ce que les français n'ont
pas consommé contenu du confinement du
couvre-feu et seat
je sais que quand on a une famille
nombreuse on a besoin d'eux et royal
infrax en seconde je peux transformer le
billet de 50 50 si on pouvait
transformer les 10,5 euros
travailler c'est de nature à vous
rassurer que les gens puissent venir à
20h et partir un peu plus tard boys ah
ben ça va peut-être sauver nos théâtres
le personnel après il faut être honnête
l'ailé les salariés de toute la culture
pour la plupart ont touché le le chômage
partiel et c'est quelque chose
d'extraordinaire
à part ça les frais fixes les charges de
l'urssaf tout ça personne n'était en
confinement je vous rassure
et personne ne nous ait oubliés pendant
tout ce temps là ils sont en train de
nous tuer de mettre déduit et de dior à
la vue des millions de gens mal à vue
voilà oui comprenne qu'il va falloir
nous ouvrir des règles sanitaires
pourquoi on est les pestiférés de du
pays nous pourquoi on attraperait des
maladies dans nos restaurants alors que
les gens pendant leur [ __ ] de cantine
à l'assemblée nationale c'est là qu'en
images pas la cantine il m'a descendu
sur les trottoirs j
thaksin et ce soir pascal parce qu'il
sait qu'il a été très critique toute la
semaine donc moi j'attends au virage
comment vous réinventez par la suite
parce que c'est ça la question pour tous
les restaurants
j'ai horreur de ce mot alors j'ai
horreur de ce mot réinventer on ne se
réinvente pas on s'adapte
sa vie des rebuts et d'eau fraîche
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui allô braille d'actualité une souris
bloch demande à une autre a entendu
votre faire vacciner des folles répond
l'autre ils n'ont pas fini les tests sur
les humains c'est pas mal le 28 novembre
les commerces pourront rouvrir en
respectant un protocole sanitaires
strictes les déplacements pour motif de
promenades seront étendus ils seront
désormais autorisés dans un rayon de 20
km et pour trois heures
enfin les offices religieux seront à
nouveau permis dans la stricte limite de
30 personnes 30 personnes pour les
messes
que ce soit dans la cathédrale de
chartres oui que ce soit dans une petite
église de village c'est le même nombre
c'est absurde c'est vrai c'est ridicule
comment on choisit les 30
et comment l'entrée de ligue 1 ces
derniers deniers du mont à leux relevé
bombe à vous vous avez le droit de
passer trêve de plaisanterie c'est
absolument absurde
s'il vous plaît mon oncle ma grand mère
si vous m'entendez fait en sorte que ce
jour soit pas celui où je tromperait ma
copine je la tromperait pas je la
tromperait pas j'aime vraiment ma copine
mais avec toutes ces tentations autour
de moi et les filles mettent pas du tout
ne pas tromper ne pas trouver voulez
vous coucher
moi ce soir voulez vous coucher avec la
personne qui répond je crois qu'à
personne qui veut coucher avec toi
bonjour en fout vaut mieux être seul que
mal accompagné d'une loi critiquée et
moqué des internautes floute le visage
de policiers de fiction pour tourner en
dérision la loi de sécurité globale
comme le texte prévoit d'interdire la
diffusion des images de policiers à des
fins malveillantes
voilà robocop anonymisées même
traitement pour dupont et dupond
l'inspecteur gadget et votre personnage
de dessin animé
allez c'est bon la coiffure et tous
genres et entremêlant ah oui oui c'est
vrai je suis content on s'en fout alors
je vous présente mon collègue fred
il paraît qu'on se rassemble on coupe la
bûche de noël en deux papys et mamies
manche dans la cuisine et nous sommes en
jeu dans le dans la salle à manger voilà
au couple à bûches et on envoie papis et
mamies la manger dans la cuisine l'idée
a fait bondir les internautes
tant qu'on y est on peut couper mes
papis et mamies et les manger dans le
salon et sarah nous dit qu'ils doivent
manger dans la cuisine est encore s'ils
sont trop pénible ils iront directement
à la cave
ils ont déjà de la chance qu'on les
invite pour les fêtes seule fois de
l'année où ils sortent de l'époque
amoureusement mercotte
à l'échelon de la petite mercato dirait
pas comme ça cache bien son jeu
ban a écrit la recette je pense qu'elle
était très très très loin
elle devait pas penser un gâteau chauffe
montre épuré à la shiden fame le monde
là je vais lui faire un orgasme
culinaire à la mer quatre là ça fera
bien longtemps que l'on aura plus du
golfeur alors ce petit bébé à bas en
tout cas en direct
ils vont bien que c'est un petit garçon
son zizi
on s'est d'ailleurs montré à l'écouté
ils sont fiers de sa mère quelle que
soit la zone sa va être championne dans
les années 90
annonçait qu'il porte un bonnet b le
père noël pâques un bonnet rouge
[Musique]
gildas et beverly qui donne du charbon
aux enfants pas sages à noël c'est pas
d'une sur ces questions mais comme tous
les pères noël
les sept nains voile à la crèche mois
après mois les enfants en même temps les
sept nains de noël on ne voit pas trop
beverly donald trump a gracié une dinde
sardiniers maïs a donc été gracié hier
soir elle a été sauvé de la casserole
par donald trump c'est la tradition à
thanksgiving
elle a obtenu en fait cette grâce avait
après un vote sur twitter elle était en
concurrence avec une autre d'inde
elle a donc gagné elle a été épargnée et
la candidate malheureuse va aussi être
graciée par donald trump c'est aussi la
tradition non non non morio
diego armando maradona à la ccni tanios
lamentablement intense cia officialisé
confirme en ldc sur la mort d'un des
romans de maradona a beaucoup tiempo la
barre combien sendai